woh Here Comes Godzilla again but here's
why Godzilla minus one looks to be the
most interesting take on the Monstrous
Kaiju in years Godzilla minus one had
its theatrical debut in Japan on
November 3rd 2023 the same day that the
original Godzilla was released in 1954
before this the film had its red carpet
Premiere in Tokyo on October 18th and
will act as a closing film at the Tokyo
Film Festival minus one will have its
North American debut on December 1st
following to Shin Godzilla the studio
announced that it would not be able to
produce another liveaction Godzilla film
until after 2020 as part of its deal
with legendary pictures producers of the
monsterverse during that time the
company primarily turned to making anime
content featuring Godzilla for Netflix
including a 3D animated film Trilogy
released between 2017 and 2018 and the
series titled Godzilla singular point it
wouldn't be until November 3rd 2022 that
a then entitled Toho producer Godzilla
film was announced to commemorate the
franchise's 70th
Anniversary while the Godzilla franchise
has long explored Humanity's
relationship with nuclear weapons only
the original 1954 film directly contends
with the postwar trauma experienced by
Japan at the time the devastating 1945
atomic bomb attacks of Hiroshima and
Nagasaki were still fresh in the minds
of audiences Godzilla stood as a living
breathing metaphor for the unforgiving
destruction that such super weapons can
create which is part of what has helped
the Kaiju King Stand Out from other
movie Monsters Godzilla minus one seems
to be taking this a step further taking
place in the direct aftermath of World
War II as Japan is still recovering from
the devastation there may even be a
Darkly spiritual side to the story as
writer and director tekashi yamazaki has
been open about finding inspiration from
2001's Godzilla Mothra and King gadora
giant monsters all out attack the film
sees the Forgotten Souls of World War II
soldiers possess and use Godzilla as an
instrument for their Revenge whichever
direction it takes Godzilla minus one is
shaping up to be amongst the most
chilling entries in the franchise it's
Godzilla starring in the lead roles of
Godzilla minus one aranos kamiki and
Minami hamabe the two characters are War
survivors who meet each other in a
devastated Japan the two actors start
alongside one another in the drama
series ranman buts were offered their
roles in minus one before working on the
show Miki became well known for voicing
several characters for Studio jibli
during his younger years his first was
Bo the giant baby from hayo Miaki
Spirited Away over the years he voiced
characters in other jibli films such as
H's Moving Castle and The Secret World
of ar8 as well as other notable anime
films such as Summer Wars your name and
suzume he also appeared in other
well-known Japanese franchise entries
like kman Ryder agito doraman the beas
dinosaur 2006 and even velan 3.0 plus
1.0 twice Upon a Time in 2006 he earned
a Japan Academy film prize as best
newcomer of the year for his role in The
Great yo-kai War Amar B had been active
in the industry since 2012 but became
widely recognized for her role in 2017's
let me eat your pancreas the role earned
her a newcomer prize from the Japan
Academy Awards in 2018 she has since SED
in numerous films and TV shows including
minus one tekashi yamazaki 2019 film The
Great War of Archimedes and 2023 is shin
kman riter directing Godzilla minus
Swan's prolific filmmaker tekashi
yamazaki along with directing the movie
he also wrote the film screenplay and
supervised its visual effects yamazaki
has become a celebrated director
throughout Japan after working at the
animation house shiroi in the late 1980s
he ventured out to create his own films
starting with the 2000 sci-fi fantasy
juvenile yam makazi gained notoriety
after helming 2005's always Sun set on
Third Street the film won big at the
Japan Academy Awards taking home 12
prizes including a Best Director and
screenplay win for yamazaki he went on
to helmets two sequels with 2007's
always sunset on Third Street 2 having a
notable Cameo from a fully computer
generated Godzilla towards the beginning
he has also successfully adapted several
notable anime and manga titles such as
2010's Space Battleship Yamato 2014
standby me Doran and 2019 the third the
first yamazaki also had a hand in crate
in Godzilla the ride giant monsters
ultimate battle for the Sabu and
amusement park in Tokyo in the film's
official press release yamazaki Shar I
think this is a culmination of all the
films I've made to date and one that
deserves to be experienced rather than
watched in the theater I hope you will
experience the most terrifying Godzilla
in the best possible environment
yamazaki is also credited as a sole
screenwriter of Godzilla minus one
following his 2019 film The Great War of
Archimedes yamazaki was picked to take
on Godzilla minus one and it took him 3
years to complete the script
interestingly Godzilla minus one has two
very different ratings depending on
where you see the film the film
classification and rating organization
also known as aene in Japan granted the
film a g classification meanwhile minus
one has been given a PG-13 rating by the
motion Picture Association in the United
States the mpa bestowed this rating upon
the movie for its creature violence and
action this drastic difference in film
ratings is certainly interesting to
compare a g- rating wouldn't seem weird
for some of the more family oriented
Godzilla entries but Godzilla minus one
is an entirely different Beast judging
from the trailers alone ratings of the
previous Godzilla films aren't widely
available so it's hard to determine how
minus one Stacks up in this department
compared to some of the other more
mature efforts within the franchise the
film will likely contain its fair share
of harrowing moments but the overall
experience shouldn't deter younger
viewers in the end it is ultimately up
to parents to know how much their
children can handle while Godzilla minus
one appears to be a standalone entry the
film's arrival is a great opportunity
for newcomers to the long running
franchise to see what all the first is
about with over 36 films en counting
spanning nearly 70 years the good news
is that the series which is split into
four distinct eras known as Sher haay
Millennium and Raya doesn't share a
singular continuity and you can watch
nearly any entry out of order ISO
Honda's 19 1954 Godzilla is a mustat not
only for introducing the iconic
character but also for its cultural and
social significance and the grander
context of Cinema history nothing can
save the city now aess installments that
are worth checking out include Godzilla
versus King Gora and Godzilla versus dto
Roya Godzilla mro and King gadora giant
monsters all out attack Godzilla against
Mecca Godzilla and Godzilla Tokyo SOS
are amongst the standout films in the
Millennium the r era that minus one is
part of currently consists of shin
Godzilla and an anime Trilogy starting
with 2017's Godzilla Planet Of Monsters
and ending with Godzilla the planet eer
before the American release Godzilla
minus one earned a Solid 4 out of five
fan rating on Japanese review aggregator
film marks barely higher than the
critically acclaimed Shin Godzilla
critics have been similarly
complimentary polygon's Chris plant
praise the film calling it The throwback
Godzilla fans have been waiting for and
saying that it Faithfully follows up on
the success of shin Godzilla Richard
Eisen of anime News Network called the
movie fantastic writing its premise is a
great one and watching the various
characters come together to try to
defeat Godzilla when their resources are
so limited is incredibly engaging even
Gareth Edwards director of 2014's
Godzilla has spoken out in celebration
of the film he told Japan's cinema today
there were a lot of things that I felt
were very new for Godzilla and I felt
jealous the whole time I was watching
the movie this is what a Godzilla mov
movie should be for decades Godzilla
movies were defined by the other Kaiju
involved Godzilla versus Mothra Godzilla
versus Mecca Godzilla Godzilla versus
mega geus and many others all brought in
Titanic foes for Godzilla to fight
sometimes he was a hero sometimes he was
a villain but these battles were a
constant centerpiece regardless of the
[Music]
plot that approach has remained Central
to the monsterverse version of Godzilla
but the Japanese rayway era films
Godzilla movies produced from 2016
onwards have largely drifted away from
the monster versus monster structure of
the 70s ' 80s and '90s like Shing
Godzilla before it Godzilla minus one
only features one Kaiju the big guy with
his name on the poster though it's set
at a very different point in time than
its immediate predecessor minus one is
still focused on Humanity's struggle
against Godzilla both recent live action
films from Toho take a more thematically
Rich approach with Godzilla being as
much a symbol of real world issues as he
is a giant monster when the story
revolves around a giant Kaiju door those
more literary ideas can be harder to
explore fans of the old movies might be
disappointed that we're only getting
Godzilla here again but there's still
hope that too could produce a classic
Kaiju Battle at some point in the future
we've had them in recent anime movies in
the monsterverse but Soho hasn't
featured a liveaction Kaiju Battle for
Godzilla since 2004's godz Zilla final
wars since Godzilla minus one is a new
independent story fans might be
wondering what version of the famous
Kaiju we're getting while the trailers
feature some good shots of the big guy
they keep his full form somewhat hidden
leaving it for the movie to unveil
Godzilla diars know that the king of the
monsters has gone through many
iterations from his original rubber
suits to the slim blue fired form of the
Hess era films to the beefier orange
fired version seen in Godzilla 2000 to
the mountainous iteration of the the
monsterverse thus without even
mentioning more isolated versions like
the purple tinged love crafti and look
of shin Godzilla or the 300 M tall anime
Incarnation known as Godzilla Earth in
Godzilla minus one the fire breathing
lizard has gotten yet another makeover
but it pulls clear inspiration from
previous versions his head and upper
body are significantly more muscular
than they were in Shin Godzilla making
him resemble both the Godzilla 2000
design and monsterverse version we also
see that he has this traditional blue
atomic fire this time around as opposed
to the purple Blast from Shin a new
addition is how the spines on Godzilla's
tail extend while charging up their
projectile attack still the minus one
design retains a shorter arms and
upright posture of the classic rubber
suit films paying tribute to the series
past ever since 2004's Godzilla final
wars Toho has refrained from starting a
new liveaction saga even that film was
more of a homage to the entire series
Legacy than a direct sequel to its
predecessors the trilogy of anime
Godzilla films will share a core story
and continuity but many fans still view
them as side projects on the live action
side Shing Godzilla rebooted things
completely and now Godzilla minus one is
rebooting them again Godzilla is an
unknown quantity in both films rather
than the familiar threat he is in most
of his movies this angle fits with the
movie's lack of other Kaiju characters
but was too now back on a somewhat
regularly schedule and the financial
success of the monsterverse is possible
that we could get a proper liveaction
continuity in the future could minus one
be the start of a new Godzilla series
that remains to be seen it's setting in
the wake of World War II aligns it with
the beginnings of the franchise which
could make it an optimal Foundation to
build on at the same time that setting
is very thematically specific so it
doesn't necessarily foreshadow a direct
sequel the rayware era has been defined
by independent projects that all put a
different spin on Godzilla himself that
may continue to be the case after
Godzilla minus one
n